.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Frau Keller, ist Gefängnisdirektorin
Ihr Traumberuf?
Ich glaube, das kann ich sagen.
Und zwar, weil es mit vielen
Aspekten des Menschseins zu tun hat.
Es geht darum,
miteinander etwas Gutes zu tun.
Darum ist es ein Traumberuf.
Jetzt muss ich noch mal aufmachen.
* Piepsen *
Seit zehn Jahren
ist Annette Keller Direktorin
der Justizvollzugsanstalt Hindelbank.
Sie hat sie
nach ihren Vorstellungen geprägt.
Guten Morgen, Christian.
Annette Keller ist Chefin
von über 100 Mitarbeitenden.
107 Insassinnen aus über 30 Ländern
verbüssen ihre Strafe im einzigen
Frauengefängnis der Deutschschweiz.
Etwa die Hälfte sind Schweizerinnen.
Das Schloss war ein Landsitz der
Berner Patrizierfamilie von Erlach
und ist heute Teil der Anstalt.
Ist das Ihr Reich?
- Ja, genau.
Ich muss zuerst das Telefon testen,
um zu sehen,
ob der Sicherheitsring
eingestellt ist.
Ja, alles gut.
- Für was machen Sie das?
Alle Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter
haben so ein Handy
mit einem Notfallknopf.
Wenn etwas wäre,
kann man den drücken.
Dann ist innerhalb von einer Minute
ein Sicherheitsmitarbeiter da.
Moderne Sicherheitstechnik
ermöglicht
mehr Freiheit für die Gefangenen.
Grösstmögliche Freiheit
und die Würde des Menschen,
das sind für Annette Keller
zentrale Werte im Strafvollzug.
Wichtig ist es für sie deshalb,
geeignete Mitarbeitende zu finden,
die diese Werte teilen
und in der täglichen Arbeit umsetzen.
Neuen Angestellten erklärt
die Direktorin die Grundlagen.
Wissen Sie, wie viele Leute
im Freiheitsentzug Frauen sind?
5 %.
Von 20 Leuten im Freiheitsentzug
sind das 19 Männer und eine Frau.
Was ist der grundsätzliche Auftrag
des Strafvollzugs?
Es ist eine Strafe für einen
begangenen Schaden an jemand anderem
oder
einen Verstoss gegen das Gesetz.
Sie soll aber auch einen Sinn haben:
dass die Frau
nicht mehr rückfällig wird ...
... wenn sie rauskommt.
Das Gesetz sagt,
dass die Bedingungen im Gefängnis
denen draussen
möglichst ähnlich sein sollen,
damit die schädlichen Folgen des
Eingesperrtseins gemildert werden.
Zudem müssen die Menschenwürde
und die Rechte der Eingewiesenen
geachtet werden.
Der Leitsatz ist:
Jede Frau tritt aus
mit einem Rucksack an Einsichten,
von neuen Fähigkeiten
und mit der Zuversicht,
dass sie es schafft.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen den Kopf
und die Gefühle.
Sonst können wir
unsere Aufgabe nicht gut machen.
Die Juristen der Uni Bern
würdigten Annette Keller
mit dem Ehrendoktortitel.
Obwohl sie keine Juristin ist,
sondern ehemalige Lehrerin,
Pfarrerin, Sozialarbeiterin.
Sie habe das soziale Klima
im Strafvollzug verbessert -
und die Chancen
für die Resozialisierung.
Die Gefangenen
haben die Pflicht zu arbeiten.
Was gibt es heute?
Bratwurstschnecken,
Polenta, Karotten und Salat.
Weil die Frauen mitarbeiten, müssen
weniger Externe angestellt werden.
Backen Sie lieber?
Was ist Ihr Lieblingskuchen?
Karottenkuchen.
- Ja, den kenne ich. Der ist super.
Die Küche sei ein guter,
weil lebensnaher Arbeitsplatz.
Im Bereich Gastro,
Küche, Reinigung und Wäscherei
bestehen gute Chancen,
eine Stelle zu finden.
Frauenberufe?
- Ja.
Darum bieten wir eine Berufslehre
als Hauswirtschaftspraktikerin.
Wir werden oft gefragt:
"Seid ihr so traditionell?"
"Ihr fördert
das traditionelle Frauenbild."
Dann muss ich sagen:
Unser Auftrag ist, dafür zu sorgen,
dass die Frauen danach
möglichst eine Stelle finden.
Gekocht wird für die Insassinnen
und die Angestellten
und manchmal für Besucher,
die sich Hindelbank ansehen wollen.
Sieben Insassinnen
arbeiten zurzeit hier.
Grundsätzlich
kommen die in die Küche,
die das gerne machen
und ein Interesse daran haben.
Manchmal
kommen auch Frauen in die Küche,
die in ihrem ganzen Leben
noch nie etwas gekocht haben.
Sie freuen sich dann umso mehr,
wenn sie etwas dazulernen können.
Die Bildung vieler Frauen
in Hindelbank ist gering.
Fast zwei Drittel
haben keine Ausbildung
oder
haben eine Ausbildung abgebrochen.
Martin Schüpbach fördert ihre
Fähigkeiten und ihr Selbstvertrauen.
Den können Sie auswallen
und Spitzbuben damit machen.
Bald ist Kaffeepause.
Stellen Sie bewusst auch Männer an?
- Ja.
Warum?
- Viele Frauen, die hierherkommen,
haben nicht nur gute Erfahrungen
gemacht mit Männern.
Viele Frauen kommen aus dem Milieu.
Die Hälfte der Frauen hat selber
Gewalt erfahren in ihrem Leben -
meist von Männern.
Daher ist es ganz wichtig, dass sie
ihr Männerbild korrigieren können,
indem sie Männer erleben,
die nichts von ihnen wollen.
So merken sie:
"Es gibt anständige Männer,
die mich einfach als Menschen
voll respektieren."
Der Freiheitsentzug an sich
sei die Strafe, sagt die Direktorin.
Hier drin gehe es nicht ums Strafen,
vielmehr sei gegenseitiger Respekt
die Grundlage von allem.
Die Atmosphäre ist entspannt.
Wie man in den Wald hineinruft,
so kommt es zurück.
Ich bin überzeugt davon,
einfach aus Erfahrung.
Das sind immer noch Menschen.
Sie funktionieren wie wir draussen.
Auch wir draussen mögen es,
wenn man uns respektiert, anständig
ist und unsere Anliegen ernstnimmt.
Ja.
Die Muttergottes in Claudias Zelle
hängt neben einem Kampfsportler.
Wrestling mag die 24-Jährige,
die wegen eines Gewaltdelikts sitzt.
Opfer war ihr damaliger Freund -
er hat überlebt.
Beide seien kokainabhängig gewesen,
die Beziehung geprägt von Gewalt.
Man hat einfach im Affekt gehandelt.
Das wurde einem
erst im Nachhinein bewusst.
Ich war
in einer sehr toxischen Beziehung.
Mein Ex-Freund
war mir gegenüber Peiniger.
Für mich
war es Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Er war bekannt als Frauenschläger.
Und ... Ja.
Denken Sie oft darüber nach,
was Sie getan haben?
Sehr oft. Ich habe immer noch
grosse Schuldgefühle.
Das wird andauern und man wird das
auch nie vergessen können.
Ich mache seit Anfang Januar
eine Therapie,
die auch deliktrelevant ist.
Die unterstützt mich sehr gut.
So kann ich das besser aushalten.
Ist es schwer, das auszuhalten?
- Ja, schon.
Ihre Mutter sei Alkoholikerin,
der Vater
habe die Familie früh verlassen.
Niemand kommt sie besuchen.
Dafür habe sie im Gefängnis
eine Freundin gefunden.
Claudia
sieht Hindelbank als Glücksfall.
Für mich
war es sozusagen die letzte Chance,
hierherzukommen.
Sonst wäre ich als Drogentote
irgendwo im Graben gelegen.
Es war richtig schlimm bei mir.
Das war die letzte Chance für mich,
um an mir zu arbeiten
und mein Leben
wieder auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Nicht aufgeben,
sich selber wertschätzen lernen -
das ist für sie harte Arbeit.
Claudia hat aufgeschrieben,
wie schlecht sie über sich denkt:
"Ich bin ein Fehler. Ich habe es
nicht verdient, zu leben."
"Mich liebt sowieso keiner."
Und wie sie lieber denken möchte:
"Jeder Mensch hat Defizite,
deswegen bin ich kein Defizit."
"Ich habe es genauso verdient
zu leben, wie jeder andere."
"Meine Familie
liebt mich so wie ich bin."
Sechs Jahre muss sie absitzen.
Zwei davon hat sie schon.
So ist gut. Amen.
Ein Drittel der Frauen
sitzt wegen Gewaltdelikten,
je ein Drittel wegen Drogen-,
sowie Eigentums- und Betrugsdelikten.
Manche sitzen monate-, andere
jahrelang, auf unbestimmte Zeit.
Sie leben
in sieben verschiedenen Wohngruppen
mit abgeschlossenen Aussenräumen,
sowie gemeinsamen Aufenthaltsräumen,
in denen sie sich tagsüber
frei bewegen, zusammen essen
und auch selber kochen dürfen,
wenn sie möchten.
Hello?
Sie arbeiten in der Hauswirtschaft.
Was machen Sie da?
Ich schaue, dass alles
ordentlich und sauber ist,
sodass es
wie ein richtiges Zuhause ist.
Die ehemalige Jus-Studentin
muss nur wenige Monate absitzen.
Für mich
ist das wie ein Universitätscampus:
Wir arbeiten,
aber wir haben auch die Chance,
etwas zu lernen.
Es gibt Freizeit,
man kann Sport treiben
und es gibt sogar
eine Theatergruppe.
Wir haben viele Möglichkeiten,
deshalb fühlt es sich schon
ein bisschen wie ein Zuhause an.
Was sagen Sie den Leuten,
die von Kuscheljustiz sprechen?
Wasser und Brot
macht keine besseren Menschen.
Das ist das Erste.
Wichtig ist aber:
Es ist unser gesetzlicher Auftrag,
das Leben hier in der Vollzugs-
anstalt möglichst so zu gestalten,
wie das Leben draussen ist.
Das heisst auch,
dass sie in Gruppen leben,
dass die Frauen arbeiten
und Sport treiben können,
dass es eine gesunde Ernährung
und Gesundheitsversorgung gibt
und auch Bildungsangebote.
Das ist das, was so wirkt,
als hätten sie es so schön hier.
Aber
das ist der gesetzliche Auftrag.
Mit Sicherheitschef René Dasen
arbeitet Annette Keller
seit zehn Jahren zusammen.
Er war Sicherheitsverantwortlicher
beim Eishockeyclub Biel
und hatte die Hooligans
in Schach gehalten.
Sie hat ihn angestellt,
weil er ihre Überzeugung teilt,
dass Prävention
sicherer sei als Repression.
Dynamische Sicherheit
heisst das Konzept.
Früher seien sie belächelt worden,
heute sei es Standard.
Wie kann man
mit den Leuten zusammenarbeiten
und eine Basis mit ihnen erarbeiten,
damit man bei Auseinandersetzungen
eingreifen kann,
ohne eine halbe Armee zu brauchen?
Es ist immer schwieriger,
wenn man einen Gegner vor sich hat.
Es ist besser,
wenn man mit jemandem auskommt.
Die Resultate zeigen,
dass es funktioniert.
Dazu kommt, dass Freundlichkeit
und Respekt keinen Rappen kosten.
Sie habe den Lift nehmen wollen,
statt die Treppe, sagt Francesca -
schnelles Geld mit Drogen verdienen.
Die Studentin war 24,
als sie verhaftet wurde.
In den Monaten der Untersuchungshaft
ging es ihr sehr schlecht.
Hier im Vollzug sei es besser.
Aber es bleibe eine künstliche Welt.
Keinen Kontakt nach draussen
zu haben, ist sehr schwierig.
Das Leben geht an dir vorbei.
Vorbei, vorbei.
Du bist kein Teil der Welt mehr,
du bist hier eingesperrt.
Es ist ein Leben ohne Handy,
ohne Internet -
sie ist froh,
dass sie bald rauskommt.
Seit 60 Jahren
gibt es die Mutter-Kind-Abteilung.
Bis zu sechs Kinder
können hier mit der Mutter leben,
bis das Kind drei Jahre alt ist.
In dieser Zelle lebt eine Frau mit
ihrem anderthalbjährigen Töchterchen.
Tagsüber geht die Kleine
in die Kinderkrippe im Dorf,
während die Mutter
im Gefängnis arbeitet.
Ihr drohen vier Jahre Haft
und sieben Jahre Landesverweis.
Zwar ist sie in der Schweiz geboren
und aufgewachsen,
hat aber keinen Schweizer Pass.
Die junge Frau plagt die Vorstellung,
sich
von ihrem Kind trennen zu müssen.
Wenn eine Mutter verhaftet wird,
achtet man immer darauf,
was die beste Situation
für das Kind ist.
Das sind schwierige Entscheide.
Das sind manchmal Situationen ...
... die trotzdem
schwierig für das Kind sind.
Für das Kind?
- Und für die Mutter natürlich.
Die Frage ist:
Trennung von Anfang an
oder erst, wenn das Kind drei ist?
Die Betreuerin sagt,
es gebe viele Gründe dafür,
warum Mütter Straftaten begehen.
Es gibt eine Brasilianerin,
die mir geblieben ist.
Sie machte einen Drogentransport
mit ihrem Kind.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es -
wenn man nicht weiss,
wie man sein Kind ernähren soll -
verlockend ist, einmal in
die Schweiz und retour zu fliegen,
und eine im Verhältnis
recht grosse Summe zu erhalten.
Dass man da nicht widerstehen kann,
ist für mich nachvollziehbar.
Mutter und Kind
gingen nach der Entlassung
zurück in das missliche Umfeld,
aus dem sie kamen.
Für die Betreuerin
ist das nicht immer einfach.
Sie ging zurück nach Brasilien
mit dem dreijährigen Jungen.
Zu wissen, dass sich
nicht wirklich etwas ändern wird ...
Zu wissen, in welche Situation
das Kind kommen wird ...
Sie können die Welt
hier also nicht ändern.- Nein.
Rund 60 % aller inhaftierten Frauen
sind Mütter.
Die meisten versuchen, ihre
Mutterrolle trotz allem auszufüllen.
So auch Betty C., die aus Kamerun
stammt und in Frankreich lebte.
Als ihr jüngster Sohn 13 war,
kam sie wegen Drogenhandels
für acht Jahre ins Gefängnis.
Ich habe drei Kinder:
ein Mädchen und zwei Jungs.
Mein zweiter Enkel
kommt bald zur Welt.
Der erste ist sechs Jahre alt.
Ich habe eine grossartige Schwester,
die meine Kinder
zu sich genommen hat.
Sie hilft mir, diese Prüfung,
die ich durchlebe, durchzustehen.
Es tröstet mich und hilft mir dabei,
die Haft zu überstehen.
Sie freut sich,
dass neu Videotelefonie erlaubt ist.
Einmal im Monat darf sie jetzt ihre
Familie für 20 Min. via Skype sehen.
Sonst
bleiben sie telefonisch in Kontakt.
Ich habe meine Freiheit verloren,
aber nicht mein Recht,
Mutter zu sein.
Auch wenn es
nicht immer einfach ist,
Entscheide aus der Ferne zu fällen -
mit der Unterstützung
meiner Schwester geht es.
Wenn sie etwas entscheidet,
gebe ich mein Einverständnis.
Andere Frauen
sind nicht in dieser Lage.
Ihre Kinder
sind in Heimen platziert.
Ich habe das Glück, dass meine
von der Familie umgeben sind.
Es habe keinen Sinn, zu hinterfragen,
ob das Strafmass gerecht sei,
sagt sie philosophisch.
- Jedem sein Gewissen.
Wenn sie denken, es sei gerecht,
mich acht Jahre einzusperren,
für das was ich getan habe,
sodass ich nicht für meine Familie
da sein kann ...
... müssen sie das
mit ihrem Gewissen vereinbaren.
Ein einziges Mal hat sie ihre Kinder
in den letzten vier Jahren gesehen.
Die Reise aus Frankreich
ist zu teuer
und der Abschiedsschmerz
nach dem Besuch war zu gross.
* Energetische Musik *
Sport hat in Hindelbank
einen wichtigen Stellenwert.
Man kann Spannungen und Aggressionen
abbauen und v.a. den Körper spüren.
Oh.
- Huh.
Hey!
* Energetische Musik *
Es wird Nacht über Hindelbank.
Es ist 20.30 Uhr.
Um 21 Uhr werden die Frauen
in ihren Zellen eingeschlossen.
Sicherheitschef René Dasen
hat mit einer Betreuerin
noch eine Besprechung:
Zwei Insassinnen
haben sich gestritten.
Sie verwarfen die Hände,
stritten sich ...
Aber ich verstehe die Sprache nicht.
Ich weiss nicht, was sie sagten.
Aber beide sagten,
es habe sich in Grenzen gehalten.
Es gibt also
nichts Spezielles auf die Nacht?
Nein,
man muss auch keinen Eintrag machen.
Wenn möglich
trennen wir die Frauen
und bringen sie sofort
in ihre Zellen.
Meistens kommt es gar nicht so weit,
weil die anderen Frauen reagieren
und sie auseinandernehmen.
Wir können nicht immer alles
auf Papier bringen.
Wir arbeiten hier mit Menschen.
Manchmal
ist einfach Fingerspitzengefühl
und v.a. die Erfahrung
der Mitarbeitenden sehr wichtig.
Wir versuchen,
die Konflikte im Keim zu ersticken.
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht, Frau Rieder.
Machen Sie das jeden Abend -
allen "Gute Nacht" sagen?
Ja.
Dann sieht man gleich,
wie es ihnen geht.
Gute Nacht.
- Nacht.
Ist das immer so easy oder haben Sie
manchmal auch ein Gespräch?
Es kommt darauf an,
ob jemand gerade eine Krise hat.
Dann sage ich, ich käme nachher,
wenn ich überall abgeschlossen habe.
Dann gehe ich schon schnell vorbei.
Dann ist es meistens schon heftig.
Wenn jemand z.B. beim Einschluss
sagt, sie wolle sich z.B. umbringen,
muss man schon schauen.
Oder wenn es jemandem
sehr schlecht geht,
weil z.B. jemand aus der Familie
gestorben ist ...
Für die Frauen hier
ist das sehr schlimm,
weil sie nichts machen können.
Das ist etwas
vom Schlimmsten für sie.
Gute Nacht.
- Schönen Feierabend.- Gleichfalls.
- Gute Nacht.
Haben Sie nie Angst vor den Frauen?
- Nein. Eigentlich nicht.
Das ist nicht wie
in einem amerikanischen Gefängnis,
wo nur die Klappe aufgemacht wird.
- Nein. Gar nicht.
Gute Nacht.
- Nacht, Frau Rieder.
* Klicken *
An diesem Klicken hören sie,
dass alle weg sind.
Nicht nur die Betreuerinnen,
auch der Sicherheitschef
geht nach Hause
und übergibt
an die Abend- und Nachtdienste.
Hallo zusammen
- Hallo, René.
Ich war oben in der Wohngruppe.
Dort ist alles ruhig.
Es gibt
nichts Spezielles für die Nacht.
Wir müssen noch einen Berg Pakete
kontrollieren.
Gute Nacht, wir sehen uns am Morgen.
- Merci.
Meistens sind Kleider oder Esswaren
in den Paketen.
Das Ablaufdatum wird kontrolliert,
Abgelaufenes entsorgt.
Max. zwei Pakete pro Monat
sind erlaubt,
damit nicht die einen viel bekommen
und andere nichts.
Unerlaubtes wird bis zum Austritt der
Frauen beiseitegelegt oder entsorgt.
Hier war eine Schachtel
alkoholhaltiger Pralinen drin.
Sie dürfen keine
alkoholhaltigen Lebensmittel haben.
Gar keinen Alkohol?
- Nein.
Alkohol, Drogen und Waffen,
da achten wir v.a. drauf.
Das kontrollieren wir genau.
Genau.
Nur drei Angestellte
bleiben die ganze Nacht:
an der Loge, im Gesundheitsdienst
und im Sicherheitsdienst.
Mit Nicole Genné und ihrem Drogenhund
gehen wir auf Patrouille.
Das ist
der Spazierhof der Isolationszellen.
In der Isolation
befinden sich Frauen,
die in eine sichernde Massnahme
müssen,
sprich die selbst-
oder fremdgefährdend sind
oder die anstaltsintern
etwas angestellt haben.
Sie dürfen eine Stunde pro Tag
in diesen Spazierhof.
Was kontrollieren Sie hier?
Dass nichts deponiert wurde.
Dass keine der Frauen etwas
für die nächste liegengelassen hat
und ein Handel stattfinden könnte.
Der Drogenhund
kommt nur ab und zu zum Einsatz.
Sonst wird auf Hunde verzichtet,
weil sie einschüchternd wirken
und Angst machen können.
Massnahmenvollzug und Freiheitsentzug
sind in Hindelbank unter einem Dach.
D.h., auch psychisch kranke
Straftäterinnen leben hier.
Jetzt gehen wir in die
Hochsicherheit und machen Kontrolle.
Genau.
In der Hochsicherheit
werden Frauen untergebracht,
wenn sie für andere gefährlich sind.
Aber im Moment ist niemand
in diesem gesonderten Regime.
Allerdings
werden die Zellen gebraucht,
weil das Gefängnis voll ist.
Je nachdem,
welchen Status die Frauen haben,
dürfen sie nicht
in den öffentlichen Fitnessraum.
Sie haben aber die Möglichkeit,
hier oder hier ein paar Stunden
oder Minuten pro Tag zu trainieren.
Zurück auf der normalen Wohngruppe
durchsucht der Hund
den Aufenthaltsraum.
Drogen.
Im Frauengefängnis findet er selten
etwas, manchmal etwas Cannabis.
Die Pflegefachfrau
ist ebenfalls nachts unterwegs.
Mit ihrem Trolley
verteilt sie die Medikamente für den
nächsten Tag auf die Wohngruppen.
Der Gesundheitszustand der Gefangenen
ist im Schnitt schlechter
als der der Bevölkerung draussen.
Rund ein Drittel
hat psychische Probleme,
etwa ein Drittel
eine Suchterkrankung.
Viele haben beides.
Das ist das Nachtwachebuch
für jede WG.
Da tragen wir für jede WG ein,
ob etwas Spezielles war.
Wir schreiben auch ein, wenn es
in der Nacht einen Zellenruf gab,
damit sie am Morgen Bescheid wissen.
- Was ist ein Zellenruf?
Das ist dann, wenn die Frauen
aus der Zelle klingeln,
wenn es ihnen nicht gut geht
oder wenn sie etwas brauchen.
Das geht an die Loge, die meldet
sich bei uns und wir schauen dann.
Nachts ist das Gefängnis
ein unheimlicher Ort.
Auch wir, das Filmteam,
schlafen hier.
* Klopfen *
Guten Morgen,
es ist Zeit, um aufzustehen.
Guten Morgen. Es ist 7 Uhr.
- Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen.
Erstmals
haben wir nun eine Idee davon,
wie es sein muss,
wenn jeder neue Morgen
nur der Beginn eines weiteren Tages
in der Vollzugsanstalt ist.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Die Direktorin ist nicht so nah an
den Gefangen wie die Mitarbeitenden.
Aber sie
begrüsst alle Neuen persönlich.
Ich begrüsse Sie herzlich
zu dieser Zusammenkunft mit Ihnen,
als neu eingetretenen Frauen,
und mit der Geschäftsleitung
der Anstalt Hindelbank.
Der Sinn dieser Zusammenkunft ist,
dass wir alle neu eingetretenen
Frauen einmal sehen.
Damit wir einen Eindruck
von Ihnen als Person haben.
Ich komme aus Brasilien.
Hier ist es sehr schön.
Ich werde im Biowerk arbeiten.
- Sie werden also draussen arbeiten?
Yes.
So etwas wie hier
gibt es in Brasilien nicht,
darum bin ich sehr dankbar.
Den Sicherheitsdienst sehen Sie
immer wieder auf dem Gelände.
Alles wird den Neuen genau erklärt,
damit sie
die Regeln nachvollziehen können.
Denn von nun an können sie nicht mehr
frei über ihr Leben bestimmen.
Es ist wichtig zu wissen,
dass das nichts Persönliches ist,
sondern das Gesetz.
Sogar wenn Sie ins Spital müssen,
müssen Sie Handschellen tragen.
Was wir von Ihnen erwarten,
während Sie hier sind:
dass Sie sich
mit Ihrem Delikt auseinandersetzen
und dass Sie wissen,
wenn Sie hier rausgehen:
"Das wird nie mehr passieren."
"Ich werde nicht rückfällig werden."
"Ich habe neue Fähigkeiten gelernt."
"Ich werde draussen so leben können,
dass ich nicht nach Hindelbank
zurückkehren muss."
Ganz schwierig ist,
dass wir nicht wissen,
ob es funktioniert hat.
Wir verlieren die Frauen
aus den Augen, sobald sie austreten.
Das ist auch richtig so.
Wir haben einen professionellen
Auftrag, der dann fertig ist.
Das sind keine privaten Beziehungen.
Der Nachteil ist, dass wir
nur bei den Rückfälligen sehen,
wie es weitergegangen ist.
Die Zahlen, die wir haben:
20 % der Frauen, die hier waren,
kamen in den letzten Jahren wieder,
80 % also nicht.
Daran sieht man
den Erfolg ein bisschen.
Die Gefängnisesel
sind schon viele Jahre hier.
Die Tiere haben keine Vorurteile -
egal,
was die Frauen verbrochen haben.
Viele nehmen sich ein Vorbild
an den Eseln:
Sie fragen andere nicht
nach ihrem Delikt.
Schliesslich müssen sie
im Alltag miteinander auskommen.
Kommst du nächste Woche
in den PC-Kurs?
Ist der schon wieder?
- Ja.
Sicher?
Okay. Ich wollte noch etwas ECT
machen und habe gemerkt,
dass ich gar nicht mag.
Also habe ich etwas gehäkelt.
Da fand ich zwei Fehler und musste
eine Reihe öffnen.- Oh nein.
Weisst du, ich habe vorgestern
an meinem Tuch gehäkelt.- Ja.
Dann kamen alle und fragten,
ob ich ihnen auch eines mache.
Eine der beiden
ist Mitglied im Insassinnenrat.
Wir sind gewählte Insassinnen,
aus jeder WG ...
... die alle zwei Wochen
zusammensitzen.
Wir bekommen Anträge
der anderen Frauen,
haben dann regelmässig Sitzungen
mit der Geschäftsleitung,
diskutieren das
und versuchen Lösungen zu finden,
damit das Leben für uns drinnen
etwas angenehmer wird.
Gerade vor Kurzem diskutierten wir
mit der Geschäftsleitung darüber,
dass man den Radius derjenigen,
die 5 Std. Ausgang haben,
etwas erweitern könnte.
Ja, viele Dinge.
Die Warenregelung wurde angepasst.
Sie haben schon sehr viel erreicht.
Es ist megacool, dass es das gibt.
Die meisten Frauen
haben viel Freude dran.
Ab nächstem Januar
dürfen wir online Bücher bestellen.
Wir haben doch sehr viel Freizeit,
die wir sinnvoll verbringen müssen.
Hey, hm?
Kommt.
Ah ja? Warte kurz.
Komm.
107 Frauen, 107 Geschichten.
Der moderne Strafvollzug ist
massgeschneidert auf jede einzelne.
Wie schnell sie freikommen,
hängt auch ab von ihrer Bereitschaft,
sich ihren Dämonen zu stellen.
Im Gegensatz zu ihnen
kann die Direktorin
die Anstalt jederzeit verlassen.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wir haben einen Regentag erwischt,
als wir Annette Keller
beim Wandern begleiten.
Es bietet sich an,
mit der ehemaligen Pfarrerin
über Schuld und Sühne
zu philosophieren.
Und darüber, was in ihrer Macht liegt
und was eben nicht.
Hindelbank ist ein Ort,
an dem 100 Leute arbeiten
und 100 Leute leben.
Ich leite das Ganze zwar,
aber ich habe
keinen Einfluss auf alles.
Alle prägen das mit.
Die eingewiesenen Frauen müssen
ihren Weg letztendlich selber gehen,
bis sie wieder rauskommen.
Wir können begleiten, unterstützen,
herausfordern und konfrontieren.
Aber machen müssen es
die betroffenen Leute selber.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022